hello everybody welcome to drunk
minecraft where we put our livers on the
line for your entertainment you like
that you like that you like oh yeah I am
was that improvised or did you practice
that I totally improvised yes there's no
one okay come anyways oh we are back on
the island where you guys there's Bob
I'm right here hi there's a job do I pay
attention or I
there's a mini Jubjub walking me Chuck
it's like totes freaky man
totes mix and I kill the [ __ ] out of it
I don't think I can anyway we're gonna
built what the hell happened here
I don't know oh there you are gay hi
almost look like someone's this where
the plane was no it was the plane was
over on the way anyway we are going to
build another house and I am in um mob
spawner mob farm fever
I love farming in every way in aspect oh
by the way I'm drinking captain Morgan's
honey Jack and dr. pepper
you see what I'm drinking yes oh yeah if
you haven't noticed we uh we actually
kind of figured it out we figured out
the technology and over there is way we
think we did say hi wait wait wait hello
hey everybody hey LT don't wait hey look
Bob hey Bobby oh where am I in the Brady
Square blow Wade I mark away Bob Bob hey
Mark I'm looking down and waiting to get
- are you guys okay look like I'm
waiting is not going well no no oh no
good ha ha ha ha taking out my keyboard
right now oh no this is how many we
don't just have a failure before we
started again all over the place oh my
god I gotta bust out the paper towels
here hang on oh my god mark how much
have you had already gone up by
markiplier everybody shut up I've had a
shot
and the infallible markiplier 1/2 liter
of katan's in dr. pepper though I'm just
like getting a bunch of stone is that is
that the idea I do that oh my oh my I'm
gonna not spare my spill my very good
drink
however we get it on I mean you guys can
actually see this well I'm drinking
weight and Bob drinking this this is it
oh I'm so new at this guys I can't
handle it capturing a sheep everyone's
gonna laugh at how how horrible of a
weatherman I would make are you my where
I put my drink up and it's on the wrong
side of the screen and I was all Oh
moving it off Oh
Oh No Oh what whatever its michelob
ultra that's what I'm drinking yeah the
only aim breed it oh god it's everywhere
Jim I really how the heck you shouldn't
hold your keyboard over your head when
you shake it out far better energy oh I
could just see I can see it oh oh hang
on I got this app I got this this is so
entertaining me watching everyone
watching me clean up all my ice I don't
even get to watch me clean up i felicity
you cleaned out I know why is there
stone brick on a tree what is this if
the REM knows my house the remnants of
what used to be dick well I wasn't here
for the that tree how they did if we
blew it up oh you were here don't we
were definitely here lie I don't
remember it was a live stream they'll
lie on me I wasn't here for pearl yeah I
missed part of it wait no that was the
good part yeah everything got better
with oh that's usually the way okay all
right I think I'm cleaned up here though
do we have any is I have to iron fix but
they're both pretty low on you know
stuck eNOS on top of a mountain oh no
all this I stopped recording I started
recording again well how long did you
stop recording
no I just know cuz I was sopping up my
keyboard in it was not
maybe like 12 seconds of blackout on
your webcam don't know I don't know I
don't know
well fix it in post did I even start
recording on my webcam that would be bad
yes I did I did and welcome everybody
every first I feel like every episode at
some point within the first 5 minutes
mark is like oh no I forgot to record on
my web not recording on my webcam yeah I
know
ok eventually he's gonna be not
recording it every way is everybody shut
up yeah I'm the battle y'all suck
that's not true that's not true that's
only true and livestreams mark ok
alright now this is our world we are
starting efficiently now that that
efficiently officially now that's it now
that that is the whole disaster and my
keyboard still works surprisingly ah
does anyone have a box thingy no Bach
what stuff in s go get wood yourself you
bathroom yeah a chest that a box I got
you know got 64 oak wood planks and you
make one because I can't even collect
wood to put to make a chest to here
come iets it why can't you collect wood
why can't I do what go without oh no my
keyboard no no oh no oh no oh no I'm
just moving backwards straight Oh No Oh
No
is it a wireless keyboard mark no it's
wired oh no is it mechanical I don't
have a backup keyboard do not oh god
this is the episode where Mark walks
about hurts the entire time shut up I
got it yeah there's a chest bump guys
made me spill my drink thanks wait again
no spell today I shut up wait you're an
idiot
oh yeah yeah wait I'm over the
functional keyboard clearly I'm the
stupid one yeah seee yeah oh no still
happening Bob who are you even rooting
for I can't even jump I'm just talking
smack
I can't even jump I can't jump okay Oh
hahahaha
this is the episode where Mark loses
himself $70 I can't oh I'd get why it
broke did oh my do
we're broke did you bastards hi do any
thank you back we do nothing we did get
a god thing I'm gonna come watch you and
enjoy this ah yeah ah [ __ ] it was
working I don't know what happened hey
hey buddy why are you moving like that
hey what huh shut up Bob got your face
in this one Bob mark officially filed
for divorce
we're already divorced I'm helping the
forest look I'm helping zombie autumn
we're divorced yeah we're divorced
oh I didn't know that yeah yes he bought
the diamond oh no I had to sign some
paperwork or something oh that's sad not
right you look nice won't you um let you
move around and show everybody how you
look yeah mark mark I just found
something awesome follow me okay yes
you're Gorda son my scream is 5 dozen I
can't even go this for a third person I
gotta find out what buttons working
rebinding my escape button doesn't even
work oh damn it or what oh there a way
to control this game only with a mouse
alright hang on I'm gonna your brothers
your brothers got to have a keyboard you
can use I have something he doesn't have
a computer yeah he doesn't have a Peter
he doesn't need it Oh Tom you chicken
doesn't he do web comics shut up Wade
God Wade
oh I forgot I have a camera I was
totally just slouching off camera really
bad oh I'd be the worst email
personality I broke Tom what else did
you break my screen went weird oh how
did the beer run down the back of your
desk and into your computer case
I don't know set up in this episode to
the end
Ammar computer oh my god shut up Marcus
in this episode the separation saying
this episode in this episode this
episode happens
oh come who's just working oh hi do you
have any uh aerosol air no restarick no
I think I might have just killed I think
the alcohol getting into the keyboard
did some give a blow dryer no I do not
have any of these things my mouth just
blow on it a bunch yeah that'll do it
that'll do it
sad sound I've ever heard are you
bluffing a kid be blowing on your
keyboard it sounds a lot like no I do my
uh I have one yeah that helps me that
helps me a lot
oh I'll put it in this chest for you oh
wait you have a laptop or a thing shut
up Wayne we are going to we're going to
take a small mission here viewers if
you're watching this video
ah please click the donate link because
Martha keep your face cuz not only the
support be more alcohol he also needs a
new computer don't want that all of his
keyboard money on his on his alcohol
that he dumped us keyboard shut up
each rounded in irony I'm going to take
a small intermission here we're gonna
stop recording and we're gonna come back
when we come back I'm gonna have a new
keyboard okay okay okay I don't agree to
that I want to keep recording I like
this is gonna I like the tone of this
episode I want to I like where it's
going you got
all right I'm gonna go find okey this
aware mark leaves for 45 minutes and I
bag shut up
I'll go bog of you uh I'll be the
hardship Bob this is Bob in my episode
yeah this is the bobbin wait show oh
sorry
featuring market buyers bedroom wall
which is America I've got half a heart
over there what I don't where you've got
what I've got half a heart of Health no
food all I have like two sacks of bread
where you at
Oh like a mile away what I died of
malnutrition [ __ ] if that's possible
oh yeah yeah man you have any good stuff
can I go salvage it oh no I guess you'll
spawn on it so I Bob there Bob we don't
have a spawn set up on the island I'll
have permission to go back oh summit oh
god why can't you TPA to me
I don't know meet Roy or our TPA not
warp yeah I do know I have sufficient
funds oh I don't like /type /page
knows yeah space here space my name
hopefully you have like a voxel to get
me there I've got a bunch of money
we're not found I'm just gonna type Lord
will that work
nope type /tpa here one word see if that
works
I don't have permission either well it's
okay cuz we're not recording anything
interesting
this ice buttons here lettin we're the
worst at this this is what happens I
leave for the end of one episode
everything goes to [ __ ]
also I'm about to be out of tools hey
zombies here now yeah I'm back oh that's
good don't be so subtle conference since
Marc's been gone I've accomplished death
big hug back via the keyboard three your
cable I'll I think you need one I'm not
sure which one works so so ham I gotta
figure this out they're all wireless so
I got to replace dongles until they work
I can't hear you guys are you still
there yeah can you hear it keep talking
God you inside ok ok well we were
talking and I died and I got sent back
to zombie city and no one teleported be
back for a while so I was just stay
there try to find a way back ok that's
no one can see that at all
yeah no no but the Kinnear is a matter
Wade we're not recording video so yeah
but well we are recording video but I
just found the coolest thing ever I wish
everybody could see it wait you're an
[ __ ]
oh yeah like Mark don't you lick
yourself another drink I got a logitech
that doesn't help me oh they should all
work on the same unifying reciever then
just like for that these are old oh
these are shitty tech no offense
Logitech I love their products but they
used to make some really weak ass
keyboards I've got a Logitech mouse and
it kind of sucks
I like my Logitech mouse I've got the
marathon 705 pretty good but via the old
Logitech keepers my mouse and a cool
pretty shitty probably have like an M
205 or something that you a task well I
got it
connect okay yeah I don't even know
hello my shovel insta broke [ __ ] I'm a
[ __ ] okay no this one marks gonna stand
in one spot that higher episode Creek ah
dammit connect [ __ ] you damn it
good now no this can't be happening
oh no you go do they have Henry's yeah
the Attic they have connect how old are
they they're all there from but after
1990 they've got to work what is that
[ __ ] oh you got to be kidding me
another dongle here I got two wireless
dongle it was a dongle wireless wait a
dongle it's what you use to connect a
wireless mouse to a computer
please I've never heard that that's what
it's called wait listen this is why I
was a console gamer before you mark yeah
console gamers suck ass I don't know if
I group that's the everyone else does no
matter what you agree nah well actually
probably everyone else does which is
shitty because I am both a computer
gamer and a console gamer ow
Oh Bob we've been killing mark this
whole time oh I can't kill him oh no
we're not married
oh don't worry that's how's that
possible it's on keyboard how's the
keyboard not working oh it's the worst
episode ever
haha it really is how Oh Oh
we told Tommy what's in some bill get
your new keyboard yeah we'll see what
zombie can do maybe he's got some sweet
axe this is the worst why did you guys
make me spill my drink all over my
keyboard
did you do anything oh no guys guys
rewind you will see that Bob all right I
saw a creeper at you
I don't care kill me I don't have that
power
this is work like he's the head said we
have left him too much technology what's
happening Oh Oh No
there we go
oh my keyboard smells like booze
seriously get get get a hairdryer or
something I bet it's just an electronic
contact keyboard and there's just water
in there alcohol that's that's keeping
it from working correctly or put it in a
giant bucket of rice oh that was that'll
probably work it would just take like
two days right one more time that
doesn't work then I guess that'll be the
end of the episode oh no oh no oh yeah
Oh Magoo you've done it again really
boss son of a [ __ ] I thought that's
what we were doing no-one's gonna
understand that reference I say the name
of the Oh huh sorry mark how it's okay
you're alive Phil no one's gonna get
that reference you know that right I say
his name italic I was just like oh no
one's gonna get the rose Oh mr. Magoo
the movie you've done it again
like do you think they'll get that one
did you get it
don't be a jerk don't be a jerk just
because it's your son mark
but yeah this I was gonna play all right
no wait hang on I see ya
and this I was Homer play where is
markiplier I think at the beginning of
every episode we should play The Brady
here's a story oh man well this is your
your fifth keyboard is it working
yep okay hang on please Oh keep our
fingers crossed
drumroll please everyone in the audience
drum on your desk like a drum roll oh
don't do that to me this is a command
you know not you wait you're not in the
audience I will be I'll watch the video
I'm gonna watch mark fail in real-time I
do have one let's see what this looks
like I would be really interested to
watch mark do all it's gonna say
mars-like
mark really running in and out of screen
in the corners and him staring at a
cobblestone wall hook austria for 15
minutes
well if it's any consolation I've got a
lot of stone you had that port on your
computer mark I kind of feel bad for
this boy
I can't believe he'd sling spilling
alcohol on a keyboard Farrokh it it's
not getting kind of beers Tanabe working
mark way way but did you change
did you reboot York well if you reboot
your computer with the new one on there
should work didn't reboot it
yeah no wait he didn't reboot that's
what how we've been talking this whole
time
oh shut up I'm drinking and only half
paying attention well you get when you
ask dumb questions way answers can you
guys hear me too you know
sarcastically I don't work oh yeah yeah
no no your thing Bob said keyboards
frequently don't work if you don't
reboot your computer I'm in problem also
if Paul wait wait mark was your old
keyboard a USB keyboard
did you try plugging a new USB cord in
port a new USB keyboard into the same
slot because it wouldn't use a USB
keyboard it says you slot a lot of times
as your keyboard slot well that's
definitely not going to work it won't
recognize a new port it does that on
boot pretty sure Oh take a brief pause
and reboot I think this whole episode
just needs to go down the [ __ ] but
okay we're gonna scrap it let's start
over quickly and work I can't even cut
recording I can't even get to I can't
even get to restart it I just don't
think it's not work alright that's bad
we have inches something like that
apparently you guys are computer nerds
no if you really started off with I have
no other keyboards right now oh my god
this keep this cable is tiny what I'll
make do again sounds a lot I feel like
that's what she said I did to mark Bob
did you give any brandable what you did
no I died you ever came over here ah
bread I'm moving back he's moving yeah
we're good
and we're back everybody hahaha that was
the worst she oh my god mark hey Mark
pro tip on the don't you they bore my
many Primark my pro sir who got me this
itty-bitty keyboard pulled it out of
nowhere
I am I'm Julia that's it
Oh Minnie how many do the camera okay I
guess we'll have another video to see
I'll probably like shut up I'm gonna be
the worst F out of all time this is just
the one where less stuff happens then
when we actually negative things are
happening like john waite not knowing is
a [ __ ] what you think Bob I'm behind you
ah now that Barbara I haven't actually
done anything and Mark's been staring at
a wall what we're we're building a model
farm why am i don't even have a house
get a house oh wait we got who's
invisible suede we got six minutes to go
before the end of this episode
am i playing on the world follows cable
oh yes I can we have six minutes left
I have no buddies when to watch the shot
I have tensed I have nine stacks of
stone mark let's start building okay all
right we can do that and I got hang on
okay
let's flatten this out and not be a
dumbass oh my god this is the worst
we've ever done in our entire life
there's absolutely no well that is a one
that one where Wade was pretty sure yet
an international supermodel girlfriend
was pretty bad now yeah that was
terrible
what yeah be fair I was going on a date
with this international model not yet no
an international I never supermodel
transvestite whatever wait what's up
Fischer I said model is a plus-size head
model internationally it's super Oh God
oh oh you took my line shut up
I was are anyway so we how many stacks
you got I got lots three and almost four
so what do I build this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
is easy to build basically actually wait
get us get us ladders we got like five
minutes to build it yeah way do you have
a bunch of wood make some ladders okay I
have no wood you see they had a bunch of
wood to his pattern I dialed it up build
it up 24 blocks
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven yeah Bob that's exactly what I
wanted fifteen are in some kind of a new
right one would get us ladders wait be
useful for once in your life and get us
letters oh that was a mistake
did you almost die how close were
heating up I have a half a heart haha
well it's not a good decision
Oh fell off or you're alive hi a bread
and recovered half a heart before that
happen
oh you lucky son of a gun anyway hi I'm
still playing on the world's smallest
keyboard sir is there anything else I
should build because now I'm trapped on
ground what songs you just need a way
for the ladders let's build something it
looks like a keyboard from our shut your
face way no one gives a sh yeah yeah
they don't no one no one cares does
anybody care about what Wade thinks
and here comes like a 1 people are gonna
say no and the rest will say yes that
one person who likes you is gonna say
that they care and no one else cares
which one person is that oh yeah just go
forever though she boy oh gosh
I'm just kidding oh ouch a 3-run hope
she cares did you build it all the way
up to 1024 Bob yes I did okay goodie
goodie goodie goodie I I made the
measuring stick
I'm gonna build us a house while you do
that okey dokey we're gonna need a lot
more stone by the way we need like up to
30 stacks of it I have still have eight
full stacks plus some you go as
cobblestone it did yeah doesn't marry
cobblestones fun oh why is that holding
why can't I still not teleport back
everybody laugh it Wade I love that this
is the episode where nothing bad happens
to Bob yeah you really survived that
that little bit there so congratulate or
I'm not gonna give up huh I it's a song
I was William Shatner in that song I
don't think it was actually a song oh I
just lost another like 36
stacks of wool I need more stone yeah
well you have to come get it from me if
they nurse you have Dimond armor on yeah
shut up
I hear mark I'm getting it we need a lot
of got mats
I've got mad stone do you whoa bloosh
mark pick this [ __ ] up dry God okay got
my back we're gonna make the world's
best mom farm hi wait how's the house
coming it's not I died and lost
everything again is stone up thank you I
am sitting in zombies town staring at a
sign again he can't even get back I can
to fix I don't have permission ep else
I'm gonna fix it idiot hey good teleport
to me you douche I'm have a pending
request you didn't even say anything I
didn't send you anything why would I
send you something cuz you said TPX I
said TP to me evidence I don't have any
you guys are dumb I said you should pour
to me I couldn't cut it happy gold can I
was dead Oh such a small keyboard all
the buttons are in the wrong way well
where am I
oh no my tool no you're here here sleep
okay never mind I'm oh my god
I just want my damn that water God hah I
lost everything again okay I'm gonna
build up do you have the ladders wait no
God speaking of Wadeye where's that hole
I don't know somewhere we don't hover it
up now like it apparently it's very
dangerous dammit we only have a minute
left go build oh four five six seven
eight okay and now the other side
and one two three four five six eight
okay how are you guys doing down there
doing good oh I landed I later the
cobweb and I lived I got my stuff back
in it oh I still find every funny
wait how dumb are you dumb I'm glad I
try to you admitted it get out of this
hilarious when you did Rick a friend Bob
except me friggin fries we are out of
time ah and this one we got the wash
barks they're at a wall find a keyboard
and then we did this episode the next
one will be amazing this stuff is gonna
just yeah so you guys better watch it
this is just like a building
anticipation oh yeah you know what this
was this was a minecraft machinima of a
lost episode oh sorry wait no oh oh burn
on loss something ever happened I can't
even eat bread right anyway we're all a
dime so thank you all so much for
watching as always see you with the next
you in the next video with the kid